[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity big breaking news from the U.S
Supreme Court where in a five to four
ruling the high court agreed to keep
title 42 in place for now until the
justices make a final decision uh
they'll have a hearing come February now
this comes as Biden's border disaster
hit yet another low point last month a
record
233 thousand illegal immigrants
apprehended in November that doesn't
count the people who got away with it
and get this it's getting so bad that
even Biden's adoring fans in the media
are being forced to Face Reality look at
this clip from NBC earlier this month
watch
but really what we're seeing here is a
city that is overwhelmed and in chaos
these families behind me here these are
some of the lucky ones we're inside a
shelter but a lot of shelters are
overwhelmed I just came from the streets
this morning there are hundreds of
people sleeping in the airports at bus
stations on the streets and it's
actually really cold here it was 33
degrees we woke up this morning migrants
were huddling together under blankets
for warmth
lovely but where is the outrage been
over the migrant crisis and the
overcrowding the media endlessly covered
under Donald Trump's Administration
where's the outrage over Biden's border
failures because one thing's for certain
the border is worsening the policy is
failing Joe Biden is to blame and it's
not just in South Texas recent video
from San Diego California shows migrants
being dropped off by border patrol at
local bus stops as communities across
the country grapple with just how to
handle the migrant influx here now for
reaction San Diego County Supervisor Jim
Desmond Jim thanks for being with us so
I know I grew up in California I know
San Diego quite well very close to the
Border how bad is it getting in San
Diego
well for the last four days the border
patrol has dropped off almost a thousand
Asylum Seekers at Transit centers uh
throughout San Diego County and these
people are bewildered they don't have
any money for tickets or or means of
figuring out the system to get to family
or get in touch with loved ones you know
they're just dropping them off the
border patrol can only hold them for so
long and our shelters are full I mean
tis the season there's there's no room
at the inn and we are we we're at Max
Capacity and so they're just dropping
people at Transit centers and saying see
you later good luck and you know the
ironic irony or even hypocrisy of it you
know they used to they were the same
Administration has been criticizing
Governors Abbott and governors DeSantis
for you know taking people to Sanctuary
cities throughout the country and yet
here is the federal government just
dropping them at Transit centers with
with no means of of gay you know taking
the transit or or giving them money or
anything else they're just dropping them
luckily many of them are finding or
getting together with families
eventually but just dropping them off at
Transit centers is not the answer
especially here in San Diego County real
quick question
um your Governor there Gavin Newsom
seems to have had a sudden Epiphany I
mean this is the guy who hours after his
inauguration invited everybody to come
into California we're a sanctuary he
said Sanctuary for all who seek it then
he signed several bills one of which
gave them a free state ID card and free
health care courtesy of taxpayers now
all of a sudden he says oh this is
really bad but it's not my fault it's
Joe Biden's fault what do you make of
that
well yeah there's some truth to that in
in that it is Biden's fault and the
federal government for having open
porous borders and then just dumping
people without giving us the resources
or or the housing or any anything to
help you know these people to be on
their way but you're right Governor
Newsom has has invited them all so we
got them but we're and we're not getting
any help from the state government
either yeah so we're at capacity and it
just it's just a you know terrible for
these people I feel sorry for them
actually they're seeking Asylum and then
they just get dumped on the streets here
and see you later good luck you're on
your own yeah well Gavin Newsom Joe
Biden Abbott and Costello Laurel and
Hardy pick your comparison supervisor
Desmond thanks so much for joining us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else